[Música]
Olá,
minhas amigas, meus amigos. Sejam muito
bem-vindos para mais uma live. Temos
hoje por volta de 17 18 perguntas. Boa
noite, Alice Vogel. Vocês estão me
ouvindo bem? Como é que está o áudio?
Bem, eu vou continuando aqui enquanto
vocês me dão o feedback.
Temos uma pergunta. A primeira pergunta,
deixa eu apresentar para vocês.
O óleo de coco se tomado à noite pode
prejudicar o sono? E o azeite de oliva
tomado à noite também pode atrapalhar o
sono?
Bem, o impacto do consumo de óleos no
período noturno sobre a questão do sono
depende de vários fatores. A a
composição de gorduras, né, composição
lipídica, os efeitos termogênicos, que
são os efeitos de produção de energia,
né, na forma de calor, a velocidade de
gestão e os mecanismos hormonais.
Boa noite, Antônio Renato. Me dê o
feedback, por favor, se o áudio está
bem.
Então o óleo de coco tem alguns prós,
né? Ele tem ácidos grásos cadeia média
que podem estabilizar a glicemia, ajudar
então no controle do açúcar do sangue,
evitar os picos de fome noturna. Em
pecar nas doses, ele atua como uma fonte
rápida de energia que não acumula no
organismo de maneira muito simples, né?
E não sobrecarrega a digestão. Áudio.
OK. Que o Antônio tá falando aqui. Que
bom. Contras. O óleo de coco, né? Para
algumas pessoas pode ser muita caloria.
pode gerar desconforto gástrico se for
ingerido em acesso também. E a
termogênese dos TCM, né, dos ticidos de
cadeia média, pode elevar a temperatura
corporal e a sensação de alerta. Eliseus
tá falando que o áudio está baixo. Pera
aí, deixa eu conferir se minha
configuração aqui de áudio.
Ah, tá. Dava para aumentar sim. Pronto,
aumentei o áudio aqui. Então,
continuando,
a termogênese dos trigliceríis de cadeia
média, no caso ácido láurico, caprílico
e cáprico, pode elevar a temperatura
corporal e algumas pessoas dá uma
sensação de inquietude, de alerta e pode
prejudicar a iniciação do sono. Vamos
falar então agora do azeite de oliva.
Boa noite, Eliane. Bem, os pró no azeite
de oliva, ele é rico em gorduras
monoensaturadas. polifenois, favorece a
absorção de triptofano, que é o
aminoácido que vai virar depois
serotonina e melatonina. E também o az
de oliva tem lá os polifenóis
anti-inflamatórios, né, que podem
promover um sono mais profundo. Só que o
azeite de oliva tem uma digestão mais
lenta do que o óleo de coco. Em pessoas
suscetíveis pode causar refluxo ou
sensação de peso no estômago.
Algumas pessoas também podem não gostar
do sabor, que ele é intenso, pode
reduzir a adesão ao hábito.
E como é que a gente sugere o uso desses
óleos? o óleo de coco, uma colher de
sopa por volta de 15 ml, uma 2 horas
antes de deitar e o azeite de oliva,
tomar uma colher de sopa também por
volta de 15 ml junto à última refeição
do dia.
Então, para evitar picos de fome ou
instabilidade glicêmica, o óleo de coco
em dose moderada, ele pode ajudar, como
eu falei, uma fonte de energia que
geralmente não acumula no organismo na
forma de gordura corporal, mas atenção
ao potencial termogênico que algumas
pessoas pode dar uma pilhada e
atrapalhar o sono. Então, para modular
hormônios do sono e reduzir inflamação,
aidea extravem tem um maior benefício
para isso, desde que não haja
predisposição ao refluxo.
Então, em ambos os casos, respeitar a
quantidade por volta de 15, 20 ml,
evitar a ingestão menos de uma hora de
deitar, vai minimizar a sobrecarga
digestória.
Próxima pergunta. Deixa eu ver se tá
apresentando bom para vocês na tela, tá?
Qual é a melhor forma de consumir o
none? Suco de uva ou vinho para
disfarçar o cheiro forte? É, entre suco
de uva e e vinho, acho que fica bem
claro que é melhor o suco de uva por
conta do álcool do vinho, né? Mas vamos
lá. O nipuro, quais são os pró de você
consumir a fruta pura? máxima
concentração dos compostos bioativos, os
antioxidantes, iridoides e vão ter então
a ação mais anti-inflamatória,
imunomoduladora, tem o contra do sabor
forte, o cheiro forte, é pouco palatável
e pessoas que tm insistência renal ao
problema do alto teor de potássio.
Quando você mistura o none ao suco de
uva, vai mascarar o sabor ou dor forte,
não tem o álcool adicionado e vai ter
ainda os antioxidantes da uva em si, né,
o resveratrol.
E questão de contras de você adicionar o
suco de uva. Você pode ter o problema de
aditivos em alguns casos. Açúcar também
pode tá dando problema em pessoas que
têm tendência aí a metabólica.
E o volume de líquido elevado pode
causar também um desconforto em algumas
pessoas na parte digestória.
Questão do none com vinho poderia
mascarar o sabor, né, de uma maneira até
mais acentuada, dependendo do paladar da
pessoa.
tem a questão dos polifenóis do vinho,
porém você tem o acréscimo do álcool,
que pode ser uma carga importante em
algumas pessoas, essa pessoa tiver com
fígado não tão bom, né? Então tem essa
questão também do risco de interações
tóxicas, tem algumas substâncias tóxicas
no non
e então a forma mais segura e eficaz de
melhorar a palatabilidade seria o uso do
com suco de uva sem álcool até 30 ml de
por dia.
Existe a questão que o none tem uma
certa hepatotoxidade
e misturando o álcool do vinho, isso
pode ser acentuado em pessoas sensíveis,
tá?
Ah, então se o consumo de n for acima de
30 ml por dia, pode ter também
sobrecarga hepática, mesmo sem o álcool.
E lembrando que existe aí a determinação
da Anvisa, né, de que o non é uma fruta,
segundo eles, problemática e por isso
que eles não liberaram o o uso no
Brasil, apesar disso não significar
quase nada na prática.
Próxima pergunta.
Deixa eu ver se tá dando para tem que
subir um pouquinho. Toda criança autista
não sorri quando bebe ou mesmo que
apresente o comportamento normal ao
beber. O autismo pode ser ah, é beber,
né? Não é de é é que escreveu aqui
beber, mas é de beber, tá?
Então quer saber se a criança autista na
fase de bebê ela sorri ou não, né?
ou se todas t esse comportamento.
Bem, eu tenho um filho autista, ele tá
com 15 anos agora e ele sempre foi uma
criança muito sorridente, então isso é
muito individual, tá?
Nós sabemos que autismo é um transtorno
de neurodesenvolvimento que começa no
nascimento ou pode-se desenvolver depois
de uma fase inicial de desenvolvimento
neuropsicomotor aparentemente normal.
Então ela pode aparecer logo de cara ou
demorar aí 2, 3 anos para se instalar.
Então a forma como a criança se
expressa, a forma como ela demonstra
afeto, vai variar, como eu acabei de
falar, de indivíduo para indivíduo. Nem
toda criança autista, que é o caso do
meu filho, deixa de sorrir. Meu filho
sempre sorriu.
E tem algumas crianças que vão sorrir de
um modo eh um pouco mais peculiar, né?
Então, tem as que vão sorrir de maneira
normal, como qualquer outra criança, e
outras vão apresentar um sorriso um
pouco diferente, o que vai demonstrar a
atipia dela, porque ela não vai ter o
mesmo contato visual e a mesma
expressividade facial.
Então, nós sabemos que o diagnóstico de
autismo se baseia em padrões
persistentes de déficit na comunicação
social e em comportamentos
estereotipados repetitivos e interesses
também limitados, atividades restritas e
repetitivas que são observadas desde
antes dos dois ou três anos de idade.
Então, crianças que
que aparentam comportamento típico em
certos momentos, eh,
elas na verdade já podem ter a doença,
né? Mesmo não apresentando esse
comportamento de autista.
E os sinais podem ser mais sutis, já
existirem, só que não foram
identificados ainda, foram passados
desapercebidos. OK?
Então, a ausência ou a presença de
sorriso ao nascer, né, ou na fase de
bebê, não é critério nenhum para você
fazer diagnóstico que é ou não é
autista, tá? Então isso não sei porque
que a pessoa perguntou dessa maneira,
mas não é uma coisa tão significativa
dentro do diagnóstico, tá?
Próxima pergunta. A indústria
farmacêutica lucra muito com remédios de
autismo. Tentaria impedir estudo sobre
remissão ou cura?
Sim, existe um lucro. Qual a indústria
farmacêutica? Vai depender de quem você
pergunta, né? Eh, oficialmente não
existe essa tentativa de evitar a cura,
tá? Isso seria oficialmente uma teoria
da conspiração, mas sabemos que o
mercado global de tratamentos para
transtorno espectro autista foi avaliado
em cerca de 34 bilhões de dólares em
com uma expansão anual de 5% ao ano, tá?
Até o ano 2032, né? porque o autismo tá
cada vez mais presente aí ou prevalente.
Então, nos Estados Unidos, o mercado de
medicamentos para autismo foi estimado
em 1 bilhão de dólares em 2024,
incluindo psicotrópicos, antipsicóticos,
estimulantes e outros fármacos.
Graças a Deus, meu filho nunca usou nada
dessas porcarias. tentaram dar para ele
uma época um remédio, mas graças a Deus
ele não se adaptou e deu muito pouco
tempo.
Não há evidências. Então, teoricamente
falando de uma conspiração para bloquear
os estudos, é óbvio que vai ter sempre
uma má vontade com tratamentos que não
têm patente. Você sabe muito bem porquê.
Então, estudos aí com coisas que não tem
patente são muito limitados.
Então isso é mais por uma questão dos
estímulos financeiros que existem na
indústria de modo geral
e podem acontecer atrasos e não
divulgação de resultados de estudos
desfavoráveis. Então de repente eles
estudaram alguma coisa que deu
desfavorável, ele não tem interesse de
divulgar isso porque não tem incentivo
financeiro, tá? E existe a questão que a
agenda de pesquisa tende a priorizar
terapias com retorno financeiro rápido,
né? Isso nós sabemos.
Próxima pergunta. Qual a diferença entre
manteiga da terra e a manteiga guia?
Elas são melhores que o óleo de cozinha
para cozinhar? Melhores são, tá? São
sim. A diferença basicamente é que a
manteiga da terra, que eu conheço como
manteiga de garrafa, ele é um produto
mais artesanal. Ele é feito ao cozinhar
o creme de de leite até evapor a água,
restando gordura e partículas de nata,
né? Então ele não tem o mesmo
refinamento na manteiga gui, que é uma
manteiga clarificada e ela é produzida
de maneira mais sistemática, né? Então
ela é produzida ao ferver a manteiga e
remover sólidos do leite, que no caso
manteiga de garrafa isso não é feito,
né? Então vamos comparar um pouquinho as
duas aqui em termos de nutrientes. A
manteiga da terra tem ácidos gros
saturados estáveis.
É possível a conservação em temperatura
ambiente sem refrigeração. É rica em
vitaminas lipossolúveis quando feita de
creme cru, né? E particularmente se for
um leite orgânico.
Quais são os contras da manteiga da
terra? Como ela não é submetida a nenhum
processo de clarificação, ela ainda tem
lactose, tem caseína residuais, que para
muitas pessoas pode ser um problema
e pode variar muito a qualidade de
acordo com a origem por ser uma produção
artesanal. A GUI, quais são os pró? tem
uma remoção completa dos sólidos do
leite.
Então, é removida a lactose e a caseína.
Todas as proteínas e todos os
carboidratos são removidos e ela tem um
ponto de fumaça, né, maior entre 240 e
250º.
Então, ela é melhor para fritura porque
ela aguenta mais temperatura de fritura,
tá? E ela vai ter também butirato ou
ácido butílico, as vitaminas
lipossolúveis como tem a manteiga da
terra e vai ter mais ação
antiinflamatória.
E o contra seria basicamente o fato de
manteiga guia ser calórica para algumas
pessoas que estão querendo perder peso.
Então os óleos refinados, sementes que
são habitualmente utilizados, né, como
óleo de cozinha, óleo de soja, milího,
canola e girassol, você sabem muito bem
que eu já falei isso em lives, já falei
isso em vídeos, eles tm um alto teor de
ácidos grassos polinsaturados, excesso
de ômega-6 e tem também adição aí de
substâncias químicas e tem ainda adição
de gordura trans que torna esses óleos
inflamatórios, tá?
E os óleos de sementes oxidam em altas
temperaturas e formam radicais livres,
né? Já a gordura saturada da manteiga
gui e a gordura saturada da manteiga de
garrafa são gorduras saturadas estáveis
mais resistentes à oxidação e tem essa
questão de não sofrer a parte de
oxidação.
Então eu sugiro é usar a gui e se não
tiver disponível pode usar a manteiga de
garrafa ou manteiga da terra, contanto
que não tenha grandes intolerâncias à
lactose ou a casína.
Próxima pergunta aqui, ela tá resumida
aqui na tela, mas eu vou ler ela
completamente. Na live passada teve um
participante que perguntou sobre live
com Alexandre Costa. Eu havia sugerido
anteriormente, eu mudei minha visão
sobre Olavo de Carvalho. Acho que é
Olavo de Carvalho, né? Sobre Olavo, deve
tá falando Olavo de Carvalho. E não vejo
mais ele como um grande filósofo, mas
sim como jornalista. E o aluno dele,
apesar de tudo, na minha opinião, é um
grande conhecedor da nova nova ordem
mundial. Porque o senhor não considera
fazer a live? Eu fiz algumas lives no
canal sobre essas questões e não foi
muito bem, tá?
O pessoal acho que que segue o canal não
eh digamos assim não não tá muito
interessado nesse tema. A a boa parte tá
o canal é do senhor, só acha que
agregaria mais valor e o senhor poderia
ganhar mais inscritos? Não acho, tá?
Talvez é, poderia ser, mas não seria
significativo. Sendo que os globalistas
estão ditando as normas da saúde mundial
e provavelmente criaram as tá tá tá.
Você abre o formulário e deixa nos fazer
perguntas,
escolhas as que vai perguntar. Olha, se
ele topasse fazer até um
digamos uma live na comunidade fechada,
eu não veria problema não, tá? Na
comunidade aberta, eu conversei com a
Helen, que me ajuda lá com os vídeos e a
gente pensou que não é tão interessante
fazer na comunidade aberta esse tipo de
material, que pode gerar problemas pro
canal. Vocês sabem que tá acontecendo
aí, né?
Que que o Supremo Tribunal Federal fez
ultimamente, né? Eles estão instituindo
oficialmente a censura. Já existia a
censura no YouTube, agora vai piorar
cada vez mais. E eu tenho que pensar na
longevidade do canal. Vocês sabem que eu
fiquei praticamente seis meses sem
produzir material na parte aberta do
canal por conta das retaliações do
YouTube. Então eu prefiro ser muito
cauteloso agora com o material que eu
vou produzir. Eu sei que eu fiz um vídeo
recente sobre proteín spike, mas para te
falar a verdade eu me arrependi. Eu não
vou mais eh ficar tocando muita em
polêmica no canal para o canal não
implodir, tá?
Próxima pergunta.
Tem que descer aqui. Pronto.
TDH pode ser confundido com o autismo,
não, tá? É só para leigos, tá?
O TDH e o autismo são sim transtorno de
neurodesenvolvimento
e são resultado de interações complexas
entre genética, exposição a toxinas,
desequilíbrios nutricionais, disbiose,
inflamações crônicas. Tem alguns
sintomas em comum, que é o caso da
dificuldade de atenção, a impulsividade
e comportamentos repetitivos, mas para
por aí, tá? O TDH
é a dificuldade de manter a atenção em
tarefas variadas,
né? Isso não é uma característica
marcante no autismo, tá? O autismo tem
um outro padrão, tá? Sim, é possível o
autista ter dificuldade de manter a
atenção, porém tá mais associado à
evitação social e preferência por
rotinas do que falta de atenção. O TDAH
geralmente também tem hiperatividade,
que é o H da sigla, né? Não é
obrigatório. Tem gente que só tem
problema de atenção e não tem
hiperatividade. E tem outros que tem
hiperatividade e não tem problema de
atenção. Então existe as três situações,
tá? Os dois juntos e os dois separados.
Então, no caso do TDAH é comum ter
hiperatividade, agitação, inquietude. E
no autismo,
a agitação acontece em situações
específicas, tá, de sobrecarga
sensorial.
Em relação à repetição de
comportamentos, eh, TDH geralmente não
tem ou pode ser ocasional em tarefas
monótonas. E no autismo, a repetição é
bem frequente e é estereotipada.
Em questão de regulação emocional, TDH,
eh, considera-se que a maioria é
impulsiva. E no autismo não existe essa
impulsividade, mas pode haver respostas
emocionais atípicas.
Acho que eu escutei a campanha tocando
aqui fora, mas eu não vou poder atender
agora, né?
Então, em relação à abordagem funcional,
você pode até optar por tratamentos bem
parecidos pras duas condições, né?
Porque na verdade é tudo que faz bem pro
cérebro, é otimizar nutrientes, ômega-3,
zinco, vitamina B6, magnésio, regular o
intestino, o eixo intestino cérebro. No
caso do autismo, a importância do eixo
intestino cérebro é ainda maior, né? E e
também é maior você se preocupar com
dieta de eliminação
e também com a questão de reparo de
barreira intestinal.
Eh, a suplementação de colina vale
também para as duas condições. Vitamina
D também vale para as duas condições,
quecetina também pode valer para as duas
condições.
Então, a gente trata esses dois casos
aí, TDAH e autismo, de maneira muito
semelhante na medicinal funcional,
pensando muito mais no que precisa ser
reposto, no que precisa melhorar de
qualidade de vida, de estilo de vida, do
que em si essa questão de ficar preso no
diagnóstico, tá? Então, precisamos
avaliar a nutrição, a disfunção
metabólica, a exposição ambiental a
toxinas
e devemos focar em restaurar a
homeostase intestinal, né, melhorar a
função intestinal, reduzir carga tóxica,
corrigir deficiências nutricionais que
sejam identificadas.
Isso antes de pensar em medicações.
Medicações a gente deve utilizar em
casos que não respondem após uns 6 meses
aí de tratamento da base,
tá? Então, resumindo muito, o autismo
pensa em déficit de comunicação social,
estereotipia, que são os movimentos, né,
repetitivos, interesse restrito, tá? E
TDH pensa em déficit de atenção e
hiperatividade, tá? Então, eh, para não
confundir uma coisa com a outra.
Próxima pergunta. Doutor, e esse remédio
novo para Alzheimer não especificou do
que tava falando, mas eu tô entendendo
que seja os medicamentos que são os
anticorpos monoclonais contra os
peptídios betamide.
Eu não gosto desses remédios. Acho que
eles foram uma grande fria, tá? Por que
são uma grande fria? Eles têm muitos
riscos e são muito caros, tá? Geralmente
o risco de sangramento cerebral e de
edema cerebral é por volta de 10%.
Nós temos aí três remédios que foram
lançados nos últimos anos. O primeiro
deles foi o ADCANUMAB, o ADUM, eh, que é
o anticorpo antibetamiloide.
Ele foi aprovado pelo FDA em 2021, só
que a maioria dos hospitais americanos,
pelo menos há dois anos atrás que eu
chequei, não tinham aderido porque era
muito, muito caro e tinha muito risco,
tá? O custo, para vocês terem uma ideia,
é acima de 56.000 por ano. Isso nos
Estados Unidos, tá? Aqui deve ser o
dobro, né? Então tem um risco grande,
como eu falei, de sangramento e edema. E
o benefício cognitivo mesmo é bem
modesto. O próximo que foi lançado foi o
lequembi, né, com q, que é o lecanemabe.
Também é um anticorpo, só que é o
antiprotofibrilas
de betamilóide, um pouquinho diferente,
tá? Então el tem uma afinidade pro
agregados solúveis.
Então ele
tem um um acesso ainda mais limitado que
é o do Canumab. Tem um custo mais alto
ainda, tem uma necessidade de infusão
mensal e tem o mesmo problema de
sangramento e de inchaço cerebral, tá?
Esse daqui tem menos tempo de mercado, a
gente tem menos informações, mas até
onde eu sei, o benefício também dele é
modesto pro custo que é.
E tem também o Donanemab que tá em
desenvolvimento, não foi liberado ainda,
então a gente não sabe ainda eh como é
que vai ser, mas também tem o mesmo
problema de sangramento, de inchaço
cerebral. Tá na fase três de estudos
ainda nos Estados Unidos.
E só para lembrar vocês, eu sou
do protocolo recode, né? Já fiz os
cursos lá nos Estados Unidos e a gente
acredita muito mais na combinação de
dieta, jejum, uso de nutracêuticos,
atividade física,
gerenciamento do sono gerenciamento do
estresse e também treinamento cerebral
para melhorar a neuroinflamação,
estresse oxidativo
do que ficar tomando esses remédios
super caros, tá?
Próxima pergunta, a vacina Shingrix. é
segura. Seria indicado para quem tem
caso de Alzheimer na família.
Bem, o que que é essa vacina? É uma
vacina recombinante da subunidade
GE do VZV
com adjuvante AS01B,
né? Então, teria como ponto positivo
teórico uma eficácia acima de 90% na
prevenção do herposta, que é uma doença
provocada pelo mesmo vírus da varicela,
que é a catapora, né? Então, seria a
catapora zoster, né? Que provoca
catapora, que é a varicela e também
provoca o episóster.
Então essa vacina reduzoria a neuralgia
pósherpética, que é aquela inflamação
que dá no nervo do rosto geralmente, mas
pode dar em outras partes do corpo.
E essa vacina não tem componente de
vírus vivo, tá? Então
ele tem um ponto de atenção que é um
adjuvante potente que pode gerar picos
inflamatórios, reações locais. Advante é
o que eles usam na vacina para aumentar
a resposta do semimune, tá, ao antígeno.
Então tem que ter muita cautela porque
essa vacina pode provocar doença
autoimune, especialmente pessoas já que
têm sinais desse tipo de problema.
Então, cautela em perfis autoimunes ou
pessoas que têm inflamação elevada.
Então, eh, dentro da medicina funcional,
a gente tem uma preocupação em relação
aos herimer, como eu disse, otimizando
nutrição, otimizando a parte de
desinflamação,
desintoxicação, equilíbrio da
microbiota,
exercício físico, exercício cerebral e
também gerenciamento do sono estress.
Então essa vacina eu recomendo, eu diria
depende, tá? Mas eu digo para vocês que
na maioria dos casos eu não recomendaria
com o objetivo de evitar o alzheimer.
Eu, eu na verdade eu eu o que eu
recomendaria era o uso da elisina,
aminoácido antiviral e em alguns casos o
uso, né, se a pessoa tivesse uma
comprovação de uma infecção crônica por
herps, né, ou porsa,
utilizar
a no caso o antiviral mesmo, tá? A
vacina, eu fico um pouco com pé atrás, a
não ser que a pessoa tenha tido duas
crises ou mais de herpes aí poderia até
justificar o risco, tá?
Lembrando que quem for fazer vacina é
muito importante tomar vitamina D para
fortalecer o sistema imune para não
gerar doenças autoimunes, tá? Também e a
questão do zinco, a questão da vitamina
C, dos polifenóis e probióticos.
Próxima pergunta. Até que idade se deve
fazer a mamografia e o exame de Papa
Nicolau?
A mamografia, pelos
eh guidelines, né, as diretrizes
oficiais, seia deveria fazer entre 40 a
74 anos de idade. 40 a 74 anos de idade.
Eu recomendaria fazer a cada 3 anos. A
recomendação oficial é a cada 1 ano
fazer a mamografia.
Após 75 anos de idade, tem que avaliar
caso a caso se vale a pena ou não fazer.
Na maioria dos casos, não vale a pena
fazer mamografia depois de 75.
Lembrando que existe a exposição a
radiação cumulativa, por isso que eu
recomendo fazer a cada 3 anos. E existe
casos de falso positivo e bióps que são
feitas de maneira desnecessária.
Já o Papa Nicolau é feito entre os 25
anos e os 64 anos.
e geralmente a cada 3 anos.
E após 64 anos pode se interromper se o
histórico for de três exames normais
consecutivos.
Para que que se faz para panicoló?
Principalmente por causa do câncer de
colo uterino, né? Para você detecção,
fazer detecção precoce de lesões
précancerosas
e assim reduzir a incidência e
mortalidade, né? ainda é um câncer
importante no Brasil de col uterino.
Então, em pacientes que têm fatores de
risco aumentado, ou seja, histórico
familiar forte, seja de câncer de mama,
que é o principal desses cânceres que
tem mais a ver com genética, né, eu
tiver aquela mutação do BRCA1, BRCA2,
você pode estender o rastreio após os 74
anos de idade.
Se houver essas situações.
Próxima pergunta.
Deixa eu mexer aqui na tela. Quais são
as melhores opções e marcas de
probióticos para idoso que teve que
tomar antibiótico?
Aí eu vou falar aqui de algumas marcas
internacionais e algumas nacionais, tá?
Internacionais.
Tem o Flor, que é o Sacaromisses Bulard.
Deixa eu colocar isso aqui no
aqui na no chat para vocês lerem,
tá? Quem quiser ver tá no chat, tá? Eu
não vou colocar na tela não, para não
atrapalhar a leitura aqui do das
perguntas.
Você tem o Culturelli, que é o
Lactobacilos Raminosos GG, tá? É outro
internacional bom. Se você tiver chance
de trazer de fora
também tá no chat. Tem o Vitafor da
Sinfor.
Esse é brasileiro.
Esse é uma marca boa de probiótico.
Tem o Flora Aliv da Sanavita. Esse é
nacional também.
Esse tem a questão de ser uma cepa
específica para idosos, tá? Então esse
floral da sanavita é mais pensando em
idosos, tá? também tá aí no chat, tá?
Então vamos pensar aqui num num
protocolo aqui.
Então durante o uso do antibiótico, você
pode estar optando pelo
pelo Sulard, né? pelo
sacaromicis bullarde
250 a 500 mg duas vezes ao dia. E depois
do antibiótico você pode utilizar uma
combinação de probióticos por 4 a 8
semanas de 20 a 50 bilhões de unidades
fumadoras de colônia por dia. Aí tem
aquele 25 B, né? Tem o biota 25 B que
você pode utilizar nessa
situação aí.
utilizar então de 4 a 8 semanas depois
do antibiótico.
Então, repetindo as marcas nacionais
Vitafor, que é o sinfor ou sincaps, o
floral, tamarina e probiótico,
terogermina também é outra marca para
usar pós- antibióticos.
Aí tem a próxima pergunta. Quando se
está com a garganta inflamada, querendo
ficar gripado, a água limão pode cortar
a gripe evitando que ela evolua. Beber
água gelada pior a garganta. Bebendo
muita água corta a gripe.
Bem, água limão não vai exatamente
cortar ou prevenir a gripe, mas vai
diminuir o tempo de gripe se a pessoa
tiver, tá?
Porque arco limão tem substâncias boas
para o sistema imune.
A gripe, oficialmente falando, é causado
pelo vírus influenza, mas aí tem várias
outras viroses
que a gente chama coletivamente como
resfriado, né? Então quando começa a
replicação viral do influenza, ele vai
seguir um custo natural de 5 a 7 dias
que você pode abreviar com vitamina C,
com zinco, com vitamina D, tá? Então, á
limão, eh, vai ter uma vantagem
de ter vitamina C, que são 53 mg a cada
100 g de suco de de fruta. Tem os
bioflavonoides que vão ajudar a vitamina
C trabalhar melhor, que é a esperidina e
diosmina que tem na no limão, e o ácido
cítrico.
E nós sabemos que a vitamina C aumenta a
produção de téferon, atividade de
células natural killer, enquanto os
bioflavonoides têm ação antiinflamatória
e antiviral.
O pH ácido pelo ácido lático, né,
desculpa, pelo ácido cítrico do suco de
limão, ele pode criar um ambiente
desfavorável temporário para alguns
patógenos na orofaringe, né, mas
infelizmente não vai impedir a
progressão viral. Então o protocolo
seria suco de um limão em 250 ml de água
morna com 5 g de gengibre ralado e 5 ml
de mel cru, que tem também propriedades
antimicrobianas. e consumir essa mistura
de três a quatro vezes ao dia nos
primeiros sintomas, tá? Vou colocar isso
também aqui no no chat também.
Água gelada, tá? Que que ela pode
provocar? Ela pode causar vasoconstrição
temporária na mucosa da faringe,
reduzindo o fluxo sanguíneo. Isso pode
retardar a chegada de células imunes.
Então isso poderia prolongar o processo
inflamatório e aumentar o desconforto.
Então é por isso que é interessante usar
a água temperatura morna entre 35 e 40º
para se hidratar durante a infecção.
Agora tem uma exceção que é o gargarejo
com água gelada pode proporcionar uma
analgesia por dessensibilização dos
nossos receptores, tá? Mas isso para
fazer o gargalo para tirar dor, tá? Mas
não para deglutir, não para engolir.
Hidratação é muito importante você
manter 35 a 40 ml de líquido por quilo
dia,
mas ela não vai cortar a gripe, tá? Ela
só vai ajudar a manutenção da fluidez do
muco, melhorar a inspectoração, dar
suporte à função linfática e circulação
de células imunes, eliminar metabólitos
virais, eliminar toxinas em geral pela
via do rim e prevenir desidratação, tá?
Causado pela febre.
Então você fique muito bem hidratado,
tome por volta de 2 a 3 L por dia. Eh,
sendo que boa parte dessa água pode ser
com limão e gengibre, até aquele mel cru
que eu falei. Vitamina C, 1 g três vezes
ao dia, tem gente que toma até 20 g por
dia de vitamina C durante a gripe, tá?
Mas dá diarreia. Então, se você não
tolera diarreia, não pode chegar nessas
doses muito altas.
Mas existe protocolo de você tomar 1 g
de vitamina C por hora.
durante o período da gripe para reduzir
o tempo da doença, tá? Mas se você não
tolerar ou não tiver saco de ficar
tomando toda hora vitamina C, você pode
tomar 1 gama três vezes ao dia. Zinco,
né, vai ajudar na forma de picolinato ou
gluconato 30 mg por dia. Vitamina D,
nesse período você pode tomar até 50.000
por dia, mas se quiser ficar na faixa da
segurança 10.000 por dia durante esse
período dessa semana. que acetina, que é
um antiinflamatório natural muito bom e
antiestamínico, você pode estar tomando
500 mg duas vezes ao dia. O NAC, que vai
fluidificar as secreções e vai ajudar na
questão do detox hepático e também na
formação de gluta que é importante pra
defesa. 600 mg de nacas vezes ao dia. O
própolis, você pode estar tomando aí 200
a 500 mga, duas vezes ao dia ou 30 gotas
três vezes ao dia.
Próxima pergunta.
Há meses eu perguntei sobre catarro na
garganta. Quando come algo fica aquele
não sei o quê. Você disse várias
possíveis causas. A água com o limão
pode fazer mal ou ajudar.
Então o catarro depois de comer, né, que
seria pósprandial, pode ter múltiplas
causas. A com o limão pode ajudar alguns
casos e piorar outros, dependendo da
causa do pigarro, OK? Se for falta de
ácido estômico vai ajudar, por exemplo.
Então, para pessoas que têm refluxo
laringo, farinjo, o limão pode ajudar
por conta da melhora do funcionamento do
esfíncter eso ezofagano inferior, porque
aumentando a acidez do estômago, você
vai melhorar o esfíncter e ele vai
fechar com mais eficiência.
E também a questão do
líquido do limão caindo no estômago,
aumenta a produção de bicarbonato e isso
pode melhorar a motilidade do esôfago.
Então você pode consumir 30 minutos
antes das efeições.
Lembrando que as pessoas que tm
hipocloridria, né, que é boa parte da
população hoje em dia, depois de 50
anos, você usando o vinagre de maçã e a
água com limão, você aumenta a acidez do
estômago e ajuda na digestão.
Pessoas que também tm disbiose fúica, o
ácido cítrico e o delimoneno, né, que é
um óleo essencial que tem no limão, vai
ter ação antifungica contra a cândida e
vai produzir, vai reduzir a produção de
biofilme, né, mucoso por conta do fungo.
Pessoas que têm problemas com água com
limão, seria pessoas com sensibilidades
ou com alergias, né? Limão pode liberar
estamina para pessoas que têm a
tendência à estaminose ou intolerância
histica.
Pessoas que têm uma isofagitevativa,
o pH ácido pode irritar em alguns casos
quando o esfíncter esofago já tá muito
comprometido. Pessoas que tm
gastroparesia que tem dificuldade de
esvaziar o estômago. Então o ácido pode
também dar sintomas pelo tempo aumentado
de contato com a mucosa do estômago.
Então tem que fazer um teste
terapêutico, né? suspender o limão por 7
dias e ver se melhora os sintomas e
depois reintroduzir e novamente checar
os sintomas, né? E também você pode
estar utilizando enzimas digestivas,
fazer exames de sensibilidades
alimentares, né? E também otimizar o
microbioma.
O gengibre tem propriedades
prócinéticas, né? ter um produto de
mercado aí que é com gengibre, eh, que é
muito bom para melhorar o movimento
intestinal.
O gengibre também tem ação
antiinflamatória
e pode ajudar em muitos casos. O
alcaçus, né, no caso licorice DGL, que é
o alcassus deglicar
demais esse negócio, deglicirinado,
né? Então isso daí, né, que é o licor
DGL, tem uma proteção paraa mucosa, o
marshmallow também, né, também o não
marshmallow doce, mas o a raiz de
marshmallow é umacilagem calmante da
mucosa
e as enzimas proteíticas. Você pode
tentar tudo isso para melhorar o
catarro, tá?
e fazer o teste. Como eu falei, se o
catarro realmente for piorado pelo
limão, tem que suspender e investigar
alergias e sensibilidades, tá?
Próxima pergunta. Com relação ao
suplemento Melotime
que você comentou na live passada,
melatonina de liberação rápida e lenta
no mesmo comprimido. Se fizer esse
suplemento numa o melotime, ele já vem
do fornecedor dessa maneira, tá? É
metade de liberação rápida e metade de
liberação lenta, tá? Então não tem por
ficar pedindo pro pra farmácia fazer 30%
de um ou 70% do outro. Ele já vem assim
do fornecedor, tá bom?
Não tem necessidade de você ficar
falando continha se vai ser 30 70 ou 40
60, tá?
Conheço uma pessoa que perdeu um braço
num acidente, pretende colocar um braço
biônico no valor de R 1 milhão deais. Já
fiquei sabendo que a estrutura externa
pode ser de qualquer um desses
materiais: titânio, alumínio, fibra de
carbono, plástico de engenharia com
policarbonato ou ABS. Se for braço
biônico de alumínio, esse alumínio vai
liberar toxinas
dos quatro itens. O alumínio é o único
que faz mal. Sim, o alumínio faz mal. Em
próteses, ele pode liberar íons tóxicos
no corpo.
Esses íons de alumínio são neurotóxicos,
são biorreativos, pode causar danos
celulares.
Essa liga que é muito utilizada em
implantes, que é o titânio com 6% de
alumínio, ela já foi demonstrada que tem
liberação desses de alumínio através de
corrosão e desgaste mecânico e pode
gerar neurotoxicidade com
comprometimento cognitivo, parestesias,
né, que é aqueles fumbigamentos,
neuropatia periférica, pode haver uma
associação com doença de Alzheimer, pode
ter um problema de anemia e osteomalácia
e estresse oxidativo nos neurônios
e um braço biônico puramente de alumínio
poderia ter um risco maior de liberação
iônica.
Agora o titânio puro, tá? Eu já vi um
trabalho de odontologia falando que o
titânio tinha problema também, tá?
Porém, ele tem uma resistência superior
à corrosão do que o alumínio.
Então, a liberação de íons de titâio
seria mínima e teria também uma osa
integração melhor.
Fibra de carbono. Não conheço
estudos falando que ele possa liberar
toxinas. Não quer dizer que é
impossível. Eu só não conheço esse
estudo,
então, a princípio, não seria um grande
problema, a não ser que apareça
trabalhos aí no futuro falando da fibra
de carbono.
Esses plásticos de engenharia que você
falou aí, esses plásticos especiais, é o
policarbonato,
no caso, ele pode liberar o bisfenol,
que é um xeno estrógeno, que é um
desptor endócrino. O ABS pode liberar
esseo.
Então, esses plásticos aí não são tão
seguros, não, tá?
Eu acho que dessas todas
matrizes de componentes, a fibra de
carbono com matriz biocompatível seria a
melhor relação biocompatibilidade, peso
e resistência.
Em segundo colocado seria o titânio, tá?
Dizem algumas fontes. Cadê? Ah, não,
isso aqui não tá aqui na tela, não.
Ah, tá sim. Desculpa. Dizem algumas
fontes que existe um fundo científico
naquele mandamento da lei mosaica, deve
ser judaica, né? que diz para
circuncidar
o neném no oitavo dia. Segundo as
fontes, a postectomia no oitavo dia é
mais segura, porque é justamente no
oitavo dia que os níveis de vitamina K
atingem um pico natural, tornando o
risco de sangramento muito menor.
Confere?
Parcialmente correto, tá?
Sim. Os recém-nascidos têm uma
deficiência fisiológica de vitamina K
devido à transferência placentária
limitada. não cruza então eficientemente
da mãe pro filho. A microbiota
intestinal ainda não se formou de
maneira total, tá imatura, porque essa é
a grande fonte vitamina K2.
O leite materno também não é um grande
fonte de vitamina K e a reserva do
fígado é bem pequena no nascimento.
Então, qual que é o padrão aí de melhora
de coagulação do nascimento?
ao nascimento, o o tempo de protrombina,
que é um exame, né, para ver
comagulação, tá comprometido. Com 24
horas tem uma queda abrupta dos fatores
de vitamina K dependentes. Entre 24 e 72
horas nascimento é o ponto mais baixo e
maior risco de sangramento. Entre 4 a 7
dias tem uma recuperação gradual mais
abaixo do normal. Com 14 dias de vivo
tem uma estabilização relativa e com
seis semanas já tá no níveis adultos.
Então não tem esse pico natural no
oitavo dia.
Os fatores de coagulação são vão ficar
bom mesmo algumas semanas depois.
Vão ficar entre 30 a 60% dos valores
adultos.
Então oitavo dia não ofereceria nenhuma
vantagem especial. Não tem nenhum
evidência disso. Os marcadores de
coagulação ainda tão deficientes.
E por que que tão que eles fazem com
oitavo dia? Já vou falar disso. Estudos
mostram que circuncisões realizadas no
11 14º dia
sem a vitamina K profilática tiveram
menos complicações hemorrágicas do que
no oitavo dia. Então seria melhor fazer
mais paraa frente, né?
a não ser que você faça profilaxia com a
vitamina K.
Então você pode fazer a vitamina K
intramuscular e fazer no oitavo dia, se
for o caso.
Essa questão de oitavo dia,
pelo que eu vi, tá,
ela é uma questão mais histórica, ela
não é por causa da questão de
conhecimento de vitamina K, mas mais
relacionado à questão de que eh eu acho
que ele esperava uma semana para ver se
o bebê não ia morrer de outra causa, tá?
Era mais por conta disso, porque naquela
época a mortalidade infantil era muito
alta. na época que começou esse hábito
de fazer circuncisão.
Ã, próxima pergunta.
Qual que é a dose de metiformina? Deixa
eu subir aqui um pouquinho. Acho que tá
coberto aqui. Ah, não tá não. Qual que é
a dose metiformina para baixar o açúcar
de diabético? Você recomenda dose segura
e como pedir? Como pedir na farmácia? É
muito simples, né? Você vai lá e compra,
não tem nenhum mistério. O nome
comercial da metformina
é
o glifage. Ninguém pede receita, tá? A
metiformina é sim um bom recurso. Você
pode usar também a berberina, tá? Como é
que a metiformina age? Ela ativa a MPK,
né? Que é uma molécula sinalizadora que
ajuda a reduzir o açúcar do sangue e
desinflamar.
Eh, então ele também melhora a
sensibilidade insulina e tem potencial
uso anti-envelhecimento.
A dose inicial é de 500 mg.
É muito comum ter diarré e gases, então
tem que dar uma avaliada na tolerância
e tomar a metiformina ou glifágio com
alimento para minimizar a náusea que
algumas pessoas têm. E aí você pode ir
subindo aos poucos se for necessário. E
a dose, digamos assim, mais alta é 1000
mg, duas a três vezes ao dia, mas sempre
subindo aos poucos, se for necessário.
Geralmente quando a pessoa pré-diabética
não precisa passar muito de 500 mg por
dia ou de ou de 1000 mg por dia. E a
dose máxima mesmo é 2550 mg. de
metiformina.
Geralmente é um remédio que você compra
bem barato. Ele tem liberação prolongada
quase que padrão hoje em dia, que é o
XR,
que tem menos efeitos gastrointestinais.
O problema é que a metiformina pode
fazer as pessoas ficarem deficientes em
vitamina B12. Então tem que ficar atento
com isso também.
Pode também ter um aumento da
homocisteína por conta da deficiência de
B12.
Você pode associar metiformina na
berberina para reduzir a dose da
metiformina. Você pode também usar o
picolinato de cromo alfalipóico, pode
usar extrato de canela, você pode usar
ah magnésio glicina, você pode utilizar
vanádio, tudo isso aumenta a
acessibilidade insulina.
Tem o banif, também tem o o melão de São
Caetano, tem várias substâncias que
ajudam aí na resistência.
Quais são as contraindicações para
mediformina? Acidose metabólica,
insuficiência hepática grave, alcoolismo
crônico e insciência cardíaca congestiva
descompensada.
Então você compra pelo nomeformina ou
glifage. Tem de 500 mg e tem
apresentação de 850 mg também, tá?
e prefira o XR, que é de liberação
prolongada, e dá menos efeitos
gastrointestinais. Tem mais algumas
perguntas aqui que não entraram no
documento porque tavam vieram depois.
Eu acabei fechando sem querer aqui.
Deixa eu abrir de novo. Tem as duas
perguntas aqui. Meu irmão fez exame de
diabetes e deu muito próximo da linha
permitida. Ele pode usar beberina?
Pode, com certeza. A não ser que ele
tenha alguma intolerância à beberina,
né? pode e deve utilizar beberina. Pode
começar com 500 mg
depois usar de duas a três vezes ao dia,
dependendo da necessidade dele.
É possível no Brasil comprar azul de
metilan em pó com certificação para
alimentos ou grau farmacêutico. Eu
compraria diretamente de uma farmácia de
manipulação, tá? Existe fornecedores no
Mercado Livre, mas eu acho arriscado
comprar de lá, porque existe muito azul
de metileno com contaminação de metal
pesado, tá? Então, possível, é
recomendável, eu não recomendaria.
Bem, deixa eu voltar aqui.
Deixa eu ver se tem algumas perguntas.
Eu eu vou encerrar daqui a pouco,
pessoal.
Não acho nenhum problema nessa
estratégia, contando que esteja sendo
acompanhado pelo médico Eliseu.
Não necessariamente porque pode ter
outros substâncias tóxicas no plástico
que não seja o BPA.
Mesma situação. Ô Eliseu,
tem muita gente que a prefere tomar
fracionado, sim. Apesar que eu acho que
melhor feito do que perfeito, se você
for esquecer de tomar azul de metilena,
é melhor tomar uma vez ao dia.
Não são todos suplementos, é mais
vitaminas do complexo B, tá? Mas se
tiver dúvida é melhor parar tudo mesmo,
tá? É mais exames hormonais.
Não, não. Que que exame? Exame de
sangue, não, não tem que suspender nada
não. A não ser que sejamos de cortisol,
aí seria bom adiar porque o cortisol vai
alterar por causa da pessoa não dormiu
direito.
Ã, então e se você for ver, Maria
Helena, tem um monte de lista diferente
de
alimentos que podem ou não liberar a
estamina, tá? Isso é um problema, não
tem consenso mundial sobre isso. O que
eu falei é que algumas pessoas podem ter
intolerância ao limão, não é todo mundo
que tem, não, tá? Então tem que ser
testado caso a caso.
Depende, Eliseu, depende. Se a pessoa
for muito estressada e tiver muito
inflamado, ela, o cortisol aumentando
pode dar sim alteração na glicose.
Bem, pessoal, obrigado pela presença de
vocês. Vamos encerrar por agora. Na
semana que vem nós voltamos a conversar
e respondendo mais dúvidas para vocês.
Abraço, um beijo no coração de todos.